I think most people thought I peaked in
my second year in the league and I
didn't peak at 21 during the draft
process an exec said that you were too
smart that was true what was your role
last here what was enrolled this year
what do you attribute that leap - space
I think we had a lot of guys last year I
think that wasn't a secret I was
actually coming off the bench my name is
Evan brown cow bear Boston Celtic
Georgia boy Valena native and she about
to be all up in my business but we're
gonna take it - what is this what is
this AK new studio just came in today
all right this is it with jeans you know
me yes sir okay so how are you as a
client like you know what you like is it
easy for you
oh we've been working together before
she picks the clothes and then I'll put
it together I know Jenna I've always
wondered this like as I look at these
clothes now be honest how do you decide
what you're gonna wear for like a
regional game or a national game and is
there a thought process behind it for me
a depend like like how I dress is is
basically like I'm feeling at the time
like I try to like mood it like I'm
gonna be feeling like if we plan a
certain team like I'll have a fit
already put together but I'll only wear
it when I feel I'm feeling that fit does
that make sense no I feel you can see in
my head I thought it was like the right
listen we're playing I know playing the
Lakers I gotta get the fit off I gotta
get the pick and the tunnel you don't
ever think that at all I mean everybody
does I want to win the game first
absolutely that's a topic of discussion
oh yeah dude you ready I ready sooner so
I'm all about when I first worked for me
always being seen got a little bit so
she hosts me look good you know it's
interesting cuz last year when they
announced the extension a lot of people
they're like Twitter I almost felt like
it was too much they shouldn't have paid
you how did that feel knowing that there
was this kind of negative reaction to
the extension I kind of anticipated it I
kind of felt like that was was gonna be
said I think most people thought I
peaked in my second year in the league
and I like I didn't peak at 21 I'm only
gonna get better from here
certain people think that I'm playing
out of my mind now because they didn't
expect it you know so that's part of the
reason why I cut my hair because people
will put you in a box for certain
stipulations I try to identify you a
certain way and I wanted people to kind
of see me different this year I think a
lot of people wouldn't know how to
bounce that from maybe it was a tough
year mentally how did you become better
after that it was tough suffer from a
lot of anxiety you have some these
expectations especially in a city like
Boston which is like they want to win if
you're not performing you start to lose
your confidence you start to doubt you
so a part of me coming into this year it
was like not dealing with that
negativity like saying if that like that
I said cut my hair cut my hair I let it
go stop caring what people think and I
reached like a new pinnacle of happiness
and peace
[Music]
[Music]
how the flavor comment is a process
without me get the close-up over get the
closer you know I mean way is coming in
I'm letting you rock I say then about
your ankles look I saw a story when you
were playing the Jazz last season an
in-game Donovan Mitchell came up and
said something to you can you tell me
that story that was one of the the games
that kind of stood out because I was at
the brink I felt like things were out of
my control I felt like you know I had
this amount of talent that was a second
backseat it was very hard for me to deal
with in the middle of the game like
Donovan comes up to me like ask me like
bro are you good you know most people
tell you if I were to ask you were you
good you would tell me you were good
even though you might not be mm-hmm all
right so I told him I was good and I
really wasn't people ask me like Danny
Ainge asked me if I was okay sort of my
I was good but in reality I like a lot
of anxiety you know dealing with you
know that whole scenario last year it
was a lot for me if I took a lot to get
out of that I called Donovan and asked
about that moment and he said you know I
have known jaylen a long time I know how
he is so I knew something was wrong for
me like I like to isolate myself some
time so not being around people or was
kind of like the way I kind of deal with
things and it's not always the best way
to kind of deal with stuff family and
friends are necessary talking about it
to people or having somebody to vent to
or having some might help lift you up
can be good you said something that I
thought was interesting in that same
story that you're as good as the role
that you're in what was your role last
year what was your role this year and
what do you attribute that leap - space
I think we had a lot of guys last year I
think that wasn't a secret
last year I was asked to come off the
bench after coming off of a great
playoffs after
a great second year this year I'm one of
the starters one of the leaders so I
have a lot more responsibility a lot
more weight to carry people had the
expectations of me what I'm doing now I
didn't have that responsibility it's a
blessing I don't look at it as a
negative thing I look at it as a great
thing I learned so much more about
myself so I'm not knocking the Celtics
there's actually needed for me to go to
where I'm trying to go
[Music]
[Applause]
so what is it like having Kemba Walker
on the team now Kimba is is like
somebody like you knew growing up all
your life just like the homie the older
and older brother has been through it
all seeing it all and just happy to be
here what's he like as a leader when I
saw Kimber's leadership for the first
time was that USA obviously the goal
that we had didn't plan out the way we
expected it to we all went in to win we
didn't want to come home unless we did
win and we lost Kimber the way you
handled that and lifted everybody up and
told us this is not the end everybody's
gonna be better from this what's great
for us
speaking of Team USA Jason Tatum first
off how often do people say Jason when
they mean Jalen and Jalen than me Jason
cuz I always almost do it
Brad doesn't allow private join up to
play and be saying Jalen but put JT on
the on the clipboard so me and JT look
at each other lips I broke one of us
gonna get the bucket like you don't even
matter
what is it about Jason Tatum that makes
him so good that affected a niceness
factor he could do the same move it
somebody else would just look better
when he do it you know I mean he just
got it some people got it and some
people don't he got that effect of for
sure
[Applause]
Black team inside with black jeans where
would you live
nacho going to right now growing up in
Atlanta one front people will talk about
you supporter coach if you come to
school and your shoes is busted up
people will like we're making fun of you
you know so growing up in there coaches
what you have when your feet was always
like the most important thing to this
day like I look at people's shoes before
I look at their face I don't know why
that is just growing up I just been
conditioned that way when the NBA style
do you like like you feel like they're
very well dressed PJ Tucker I feel like
he's the best doing the league for sure
Tyson Chandler is og if I was 40 years
old and I was seven-foot I was just like
him you got a nice down sir you good we
got everything you need
got everything all right we out yeah
thank you
okay Jalen time to take you home okay
true or false and why is the game okay
you have to pick one don't go between
the two you got to pick two or false I
got you okay
Queen and slim it's better than love and
basketball whoa I'm gonna go Foss I love
Queensland but off it off of GP general
principle i'ma have to go 11 basketball
it's classic true or false and why
during the draft process an exact said
that you were too smart that was true I
don't know why the exact thought that
that would be a bad thing I think when
you know athletes are also informative
if I intimidate people for whatever
reason LeBron and KD with the help set
up interval movement was a big push in
his innovation because athletes you like
to push back from a society for you know
their outside interests and I feel like
this generation that I'm a part of now I
think it's a movement going on and I'm
okay true or false and why I tricked you
into saying your etiquette fiber rings
true I do want to give you the
opportunity to explain cuz I know you
feel like it was taken out of context
Michael jinx myself inside six years I'm
gonna go ahead and say five or six no
say that every year I don't want ya I
don't want to do and I don't play to
lose so I'm gonna go ahead and say I'm
gonna go I'm gonna get rid of five I
didn't set you up I just asked you a
question right I don't say you said me
yes okay but the way you know they kind
of like put it out there
the clickbait Ida was Jalen Brown says
he's gonna have that when people look at
that like what does Jalen round think he
is I say he's gonna have five or six
rings by the time he is 28 you know I
had to answer to like Danny Ainge yeah
he came to me it was like you're being
disrespectful but I didn't mean any
disrespect because I know how hard it is
just to win one I wasn't guaranteeing
anything I wasn't trying to be arrogant
or I wasn't saying that this is gonna
happen I was just like if if I wanted
things to go a certain way that's the
way I want them to go I'm over it I'm
past it I'm glad you brought it up we
absolutely had take me to your decision
to go to Cal I was number one number two
number three high school recruiting so I
could have went to pretty much any
school I wanted to Kentucky Kansas North
Carolina UCLA all great schools it just
wasn't fit for me I was actually sitting
next to a girl in AP World History and I
was listening to her narrowing down her
list and the reasons why she was
narrowing down our list was totally
different from mine I was looking at
Jersey colors she was looking at like
the business climate outside like this
he was looking at all him actually to
help me narrow down my list
she looked at some schools she was like
no no no she was like this is a good
school and that with one of those
schools was cow wasn't it
Michelle yeah that's an Michelle
speaking of that process
cuz I heard a little rumor once how
close were you
going to North Carolina I was very close
to going to UNC so this day I love
absolutely adore coach Roy because UNC
growing up my momma tell you like I was
a big as you mercy fan at all the
memorabilia and everything like MJ all
everything and Roy came when he came on
a busy brought like Jordans rings he
brought like he did the whole thing so
oh it was hard for me not to go my mom
she made me do something interesting
when I committed she made me call every
head coach from the schools that I
wasn't going to and tell them why I
wasn't going she was like you gonna have
to conduct business one day you need to
learn how to manage these relationships
and Roy was one of the very few like one
of two I think that I talked to her for
about an hour he talked to me about like
what he saw my potential what he
compared it to that made me like look at
him different absolutely is he genuinely
cared yeah so that stuck with me even
though I didn't go to UNC and everything
turned out the way it was supposed to I
always look back over my shoulder like
what if we played in pre-season against
Charlotte so years ago at Chapel Hill
I wouldn't gave him a big hug and almost
like dropped its here to this day of Roy
you need some help with anything
recruitment I gotcha bro you got you got
some good clothes get your pick off both
sound agree on I am funny well thank you
for letting us spend took a lot of time
but worth it no problem precisely thank
you so much David have a good season
alright
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys it's Taylor extinct you so much
for watching my show take it there but
now that means you have to subscribe to
the YouTube channel you don't want to
miss all the fun stuff or the next
interview so hit that subscribe button
thanks so much see you soon